Kylie Jenner parties with Scott Disick
as her close pal Justine Skye speaks out
about the reality stars split from tyga
she's good she's a strong girl a source
confirmed to et on Thursday the former
couple has decided to go their separate
ways just hours later at the nylon young
Hollywood party in LA
et spoke with Justine Skye a singer
who's one of Pi Lee's best friends have
you talked to her how's she doing she's
good she's a strong girl she's just
chilling she's always been that
independent woman hasn't she always
always that's what I admire about her
she's like one of my strongest friend
she's so supportive of her friends and
she's always rooting for them and always
there to support them and that's what it
is Kylie was also at that party but
skipped the red carpet to hang inside
with her sister Kourtney Kardashian's ex
Kylie and Tyga have been through a lot
lately Kylie's brother Rob got engaged
to Tyga's ex blac Chyna last month
they're also expecting their first child
still et's source says the reality star
and rapper's relationship had just run
its course quote she tried really hard
to make it work but she finally let it
go